hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich habe seit einem jahr nicht
mehr hochgeladen doch heute darf ich
endlich mal wieder recht der tür kommt
es zu einer neuen nicht lachen challenge
zusammen mit sandra warum schreist so
bei dem nur ein mikro abend müssen
richtiger schreit ich habe mein anderes
micro leider in hamburg deswegen ist der
ton ein bisschen scheiße ja
ich kann nicht lauter sprechen wir
machen die typische regel der lacht er
muss aus dem fenster springen
weg ist so witzig soll das war das intro
es war das video so
[Musik]
die sagt was gehe ich sage euch mit
einfachen
konkret
[Musik]
oder hier keiner lacht über diese
minister wir und dieser konkret
ich sage nur zurück ins studio
konkret
ich will noch zurück und damit den staat
vom nächsten gegner haben und ich sag
dann wird diese frauen die sagen wie
kann ich koche meine mama hat mir
beigebracht ja was blasen kann
im moment einen blick
kann anders sein das ist so
sandra
dass der neuerdings durchfall du kannst
nicht immer die geile sache
[Applaus]
du hast es nicht mal mit geschrieben
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich dachte erst es war der auftakt
gewesen
[Musik]
schreibst du so ausdrücklich in diesen
controller ganz normal mit einem
normalen zoll anfangen werden hier auf
den boden und er brennt ab und so bis
1000 euro versenkt ich kann wirklich
richtig
[Musik]
schmeckt das gar nicht so
beim zocken sein controller in fernseher
wir was
schlimmeres wie könnte ich
finds halt richtig scheiße wenn die dann
für seine ganzen klamotten aufschneiden
wenn es die scheiße geht klar ist
richtig aber schon mal vor du hast dein
lieblings wetter
lukas ich hab auch
ein kleiner prozentsatz
sogar die lupe genommen zu tief rein
gesteckt dass er mit seiner hand in
hand wir müssen jetzt so kurz seine hand
ins kochende wasser leute wieder seine
hand gehalten bereiten das ist gar nicht
gereicht
[Musik]
es gibt einfach einen bogen die ich habe
mir das gesagt ja
[Musik]
vor allem wenn du in seiner branche
arbeitet wo deine stimme so wichtig ist
wenn ich lüge und ihr hier das glaubt
und im nachhinein studium die glaubten
immer wenn ich die wahrheit sage nicht
ist das für mich schon ein gewonnener
kampf die wahrheit
wieder da
das ist drachen lord also ich weiß wer
das ist aber ich verstehe es gerade
nicht er sei quasi wenn er das nicht
wenn er gelogen hat und die leute
glauben dass ihm nicht dann glauben sie
ihm auch nicht wenn er die wahrheit
spricht und dann das nächste mal die
wahl dann da aber die leute denken dass
lohmann ist es wien ein gewonnener kommt
nichts gesagt ich habe vier jahre lang
studiert
nicht ehrlich bin ich kann immer noch
nichts und ich weiß auch nicht was bin
ich
33 jahre lang studiert das leben
ich habe gar nicht studiert und ich kann
was
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
was denn ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es
nicht wenn wir einmal an der nächsten
podcast folge testen at dick und doof
abgefedert / dick und doof
ich finde übrigens mit den urlaub
und werde zwar nahtlos
geht es weiter
du klein ab
[Musik]
ist so dass mein auto weil auch mit
genauso sein mein auto wie ich fährt so
viel rauchen und saufen im auto also
darf man habe im auto zu fahren
ich freue mich mein führerschein oder
das produkt
[Musik]
sprachen lernen
das bist du danke
ruft auch dass ein fahrsimulator machen
warum hast du so ein ding ja wie ich
habe mich stellen leute wenn ihr wollt
dass sander und ich ein fahrsimulator
macht und dann lasst den daumen hoch
unter dem video jeder abonniert mal
einen kanal und klickt auf die glocke
und schreibt in die kommentare wenn ihr
das sehen wollt abonniert mich zudem auf
instagram hört unseren podcast auf
spotify und hier ist jetzt auch ein
video verlinkt